[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning
saturday while covet 19 is keeping many
american students at home
children in japan are back in the
classroom schools there have been able
to reopen
because japan with about one-third of
the u.s population
has only one percent as many coveted
cases
lucy craft went back to school this week
just like always pupils at tokyo's east
kanamachi elementary
arrive at 8 a.m remove shoes and head to
class
and just like generations before them
yuka katayama's first grade class
bows in the day's studies but there's
nothing
usual about school now masks are
mandatory
desks are barricaded in vinyl hand
washing has become a careful ritual
lunchtime usually a highlight of the day
where kids dress up and serve each other
has now become a struggle to keep them
as spaced and quiet as possible they're
first graders
so they think this is normal it's really
hard to teach a regular class while
keeping everyone safe
compounding the challenge for japanese
schools is crowded classrooms
regulations here allow up to 40 children
per class
that's double what experts say is
optimal during a pandemic
yet simulations run on japan's new
supercomputer
show that cracking just one window and
one door across from it
provide enough airflow to prevent viral
spread even in packed classes
with physical fitness declining and kids
putting on extra weight as families stay
home more
teachers have had to get creative about
gym class said the health instructor
cool and close contact are out we try to
keep them all facing one direction
and avoid shouting stickers everywhere
are a constant reminder to socially
distance
stay far apart physically but close
spiritually they read
but total compliance from six-year-olds
the principal concedes
is futile instead of banning all
conversation
and keeping kids in a constant state of
fear and vigilance
it's better to get the basic safeguards
right anxious
teachers and parents are hoping that
strategy works
for cbs this morning saturday lucy craft
tokyo far physically close spiritually i
like that